for a certain generation it's hard to
overstate
topshop the icon but on high streets
it's soon to be history it was once the
most modern millennial trendsetter
but topshop topman and miss selfridge
have been sold to a new kind of retail
giant
asos has bought the brands the 70 stores
will likely shut and that means the loss
of up to 2
500 jobs joanne's is one she joined
topshop aged just 16.
she's worked there for 35 years and was
made redundant
three days after christmas lap time big
time
yeah absolutely you know and
i have to say didn't really i knew we
were in administration but to be fair
with a brand like topshop i thought we
were safe
i can't believe um that this has
happened every day you're sort of
thinking god is it true
has it sank in yet you know oh it's
terrible feelings
i have immense um experience
um and i will keep trying but i've got
i'm really worried about you know
what am i going to be doing in six
months
there's increasing concern about workers
like joanne and the fact that more women
are employed in those sectors most
pummeled by the pandemic
last year has accelerated irrevocable
change on the high street
but as brand after brand falter the
knock-on effects become increasingly
serious how will high streets cope with
the huge real estate holes left
how will councils manage with decreased
revenue and how will we address the fact
that certain groups of workers
will be hardest hits in fact of 3
million retail jobs in the uk
1.2 million are held by men while 1.8
million are held by women
experts say that other commitments like
child care will make it harder for them
to get new jobs
if we don't take any action now and
those jobs go on the scale that we are
already seeing
potentially with arcadia with debenhams
you know there's been
lots of announcements throughout all of
last year then
those women will be unemployed
the furlough scheme continues to mask
the full scale of this crisis
and also who may suffer the most helena
smith sky news central london